now how about some good vibes this week  on celebrity family feud steve harvey  gave freshly minted emmy nominee quinta  brunson a heartfelt pat on the back for  her breakthrough success this is a bad  girl right here  i'm really proud of you what because the  way you did it you don't even know man i  gotta stop crying on tv no this stuff  no no what you doing is hard trust me i  know the creator and star of abbott  elementary competed alongside her  co-stars as well as one very special  lady who made the moment even more  emotional this  was her sixth grade teacher  in real life that's what she named the  show after ladies and gentlemen that's  miss abbott right there  just humbly honored you know that she  seemed to you know include my name it's  definitely  right all right